what will the sanctions that you impose
yesterday achieve
what what has happened over the last few
days is that president putin has
recognized two so-called independent
republics
in ukraine he has essentially violated
ukrainian sovereignty that is why we
have put together a strong response with
our international allies with the g7 to
target key oligarchs close to putin to
target banks to put in territorial
sanctions
against those
breakaway regions
as well as targeting those in the
russian parliament who voted
for those regions to be recognized we
have not yet seen a full-scale invasion
but we are very clear that if president
putin escalates we the international
community will escalate our sanctions
okay let's unpack that what of what
you've done already will will that
achieve five what it will achieve is
inflicting pain
on vladimir putin and his regime and the
russian economy we've targeted key banks
that fund the russian military we've
targeted key oligarchs who are close
friends of vladimir putin and what this
shows is that we are prepared to take
tough measures this is the toughest
sanctions regime we've ever put in place
against russia but it will go further
if we see a full-scale invasion
of ukraine and what we're doing kay
is working very closely with our allies
like the americans the europeans so that
vladimir putin cannot play divide and
rule we are completely united in the
sanctions that we've chosen and we will
continue to escalate if vladimir putin
mounts a full-scale invasion of ukraine
so what do you say to those who say it's
a pretty tepid first response that many
of the sanctions against these banks
were already in place
when crimea was annexed by the u.s at
the u.s sanctioned it when crimea was
annexed back in in 2014
and the named individuals mess so what
is what some are saying
well these are very close friends of
vladimir putin they are serious
sanctions we are only able to bring them
in because of the new legislation that
we have passed in the house of commons
but we will go further
we've been very clear that we're going
to limit russian access to british
markets we're going to stop the russian
government raising sovereign debt
in the united kingdom and we are very
united with our allies in the way that
these sanctions packages are working
it's very important that we stay aligned
and that vladimir putin cannot try and
divide the west he has sought to
create ambiguity to divide the west and
divide nato and he's not doing that we
are more united than ever in making sure
that vladimir putin and the russian
regime experiences pain from these
sanctions and ultimately loses in his
attempt to turn the clock back to the
1990s to deny the sovereignty of ukraine
and to subjugate eastern europe you say
that the british government is prepared
to go much harder on putin if he goes
much further i mean this is a man
who has sent death squads to kill people
on british soil this is a man that
authorized shooting down mh17 over
ukrainian airspace and this is a man
that has now invaded sovereign territory
how much further does he need to go
we have put the toughest package of
sanctions on the russian regime we put
them on within 24 hours
of those
so-called republics being recognized by
vladimir putin our officials at the
foreign office working through the night
to get that package ready it is a very
serious package it targets key oligarchs
we're clear that sovereign debt will not
be able to be raised by the russian
government it targets key russian banks
that fund the military and fund the
activities of the russian government but
we are aligned with our international
allies in saying that we will escalate
the sanctions
that there will be
even more tough sanctions on key
oligarchs on key organizations in russia
limiting russia's access to the
financial markets if there is a
full-scale invasion of ukraine which i'm
afraid to say okay we are very much
expecting it's important that we retain
some sanctions in the locker to respond
to a full-scale invasion of ukraine
because we are doing all we can
to deter vladimir putin to inflict as
much pain
as we can on the russian government to
make it clear to the people of russia
that their government is violating
international law is violating
sovereignty so that we need to keep
those sanctions in the locker for that
i'm afraid very likely event
will any of those sanctions be against
tory donuts
we are very clear that nothing is off
the table in terms of who we're
targeting in terms of the access of
russia
to british
financial institutions and we are
maintaining
our alliance with our international
allies to make sure that we are
targeting those key people who are
backing and supporting putin's regime so
you're not ruling out um i don't rule
out anything okay um the tory parties
received something like two million
pounds in russian link cash since the
prime minister took office should that
money be given back
all of donations to the conservative
party are from people on the electoral
register in britain those donations are
properly declared what we're talking
about here kay is people the oligarchs
that we're targeting in today's
sanctions those are people closely
linked to vladimir putin's regime now
there are many people who have moved to
russia from britain who are not
necessarily friends of vladimir putin
and who have become british citizens
that is a completely different matter
from people who are close
to vladimir putin who are backing
his appalling regime so is that a no the
1.93 million pounds that boris johnson's
government's received since 2019 you're
going to keep it
well as i've said all of those donations
are properly declared okay so that's a
yes um can you just clarify for because
i was a bit confused yesterday about
roman abramovich
has he previously been sanctioned or not
because the pm said he had in the house
no he hasn't been previously sanctioned
uh the pm misspoke in the house and the
record will be corrected okay should he
have been should he have been sanctioned
as i've said i'm not going to go into
details of what our future sanctions
plans are but nothing is off the table
because he is of course on the navalny
list isn't he which is a list for the
benefit of our viewers of 35 individuals
compiled by alexander bali presently in
prison and that he uh in his opinion and
those that he represents should be uh
sanctioned
we have already targeted
some of putin's closest allies with the
sanctions that we announced yesterday
i'm not going to go into details of who
is on our list for future sanctions but
viewers can be assured that we have more
individuals that we will target in the
event of a full-scale invasion of
ukraine and we'll be targeting them in
conjunction with our international
allies like the europeans and like the
united states to make sure
that these people can't travel
though their assets are frozen
and that they will have nowhere to hide
and that is the message we are sending
to vladimir putin and his regime is that
we will inflict even more pain
in the event of a full in incursion into
ukraine and we will not let vladimir
putin win what constitutes a full
invasion
well it constitutes um troops crossing
uh crossing the border
well that is frankly ambiguous at this
stage okay we've heard it so we
acknowledge now that it's ambiguous
we've heard from putin himself that he
is sending in uh troops we don't yet
have the full evidence that has taken
place what we are expecting
uh and this has been confirmed by the
americans as well as by the united
kingdom
is a full-scale invasion including
potentially of kiev but we continue to
consult with our allies vladimir putin
constantly tries to use disinformation
he tries to use false flags he tries to
create ambiguity and what i'm saying is
we will not allow that to happen we will
remain united with our allies we are
constantly watching the intelligence
we're working with each other i
understand we will respond
very swiftly but does it and severely in
the event of that full encounter does it
have to be a move on kiev in order for
you to uh introduce more sanctions no it
doesn't okay no it does does
well
it has to be what we would describe as a
full scale invasion but that could be on
other parts of ukraine regrettably uh
the russian forces are encircling
ukraine so we don't know exactly where
that would happen but we will know it
when we see it and we will react
immediately do you from your
intelligence do you expect him to try to
do that
we do
we think it's highly likely that he will
follow through on his plan for a school
a full-scale invasion of ukraine
and as far as kiev is concerned he's
moving on kiev
we think it's highly likely that that is
in this place
this is one of the reasons kay that we
have advised british citizens to get out
whilst commercial flights are still
available because the situation is
extremely concerning we're doing all we
can to support the ukrainian government
we've supplied defensive weapons
we're supplying economic support we're
working very closely i'm in regular
touch
with the ukrainian foreign minister to
provide all the support we can we are
very concerned about the situation on
the ground i was reading a description
about president putin overnight
describing him as cruel autocratic
intolerant and a bully how would you
describe him
well i think the description that you've
read out is entirely fair comment
this is somebody who has acted with
impunity has invaded sovereign states
has now uh seeking to
completely undermine the legitimately
elected government of ukraine and he
must be stopped what i can say is
working with our allies we are
determined that his ambitions should end
here um as ofcom is concerned with
russia today it's up to to ofcom whether
russia today continues on with its
licence or not and the suggestions that
it's about in propaganda on behalf of
the kremlin what should ofcom do
well i think it is certainly true that
is spouting propaganda on behalf of the
kremlin and one of the things the
kremlin does is use disinformation to
try and sow discord
in the west and russia today is clearly
part of that it is an independent
decision of ofcom about live sensing
broadcasters okay and as far as
champions league final should that be
held in russia or not no it shouldn't be
that
no negotiation that's it i'm very clear
it shouldn't be and the british team
shouldn't go if it is
well
i i don't have any control as foreign
secretary over the british football team
but i'm sure they might seek you but um
the um maybe the scots will get there as
well i don't know
well
unlikely but sorry well watching us
what i'm saying kay is that
the way that russia is behaving we
should not be in any way
seem to condone that behavior we must
condemn it absolutely we are in real
danger at present of a full-scale
invasion on ukraine
and
all we can do to disassociate ourselves
from russia
and this appalling regime we should do
now and here comes the question about
the pm before i let you go he's been
questioned under caution if he's found
to have broken the law should he resign
the pm is completely cooperating with
the police inquiries that are taking
place
i support the pm a hundred percent even
if he's broke i think he's doing a
fantastic job and we have to allow those
police inquiries to continue i can't
comment on an ongoing investigation so
james cleverley said that he works for
you actually he said that if he has
broken the law it doesn't matter he's a
good prime minister he should carry out
i'm not going to comment on hypothetical
questions but i completely agree with
james he's a good prime minister he's
doing a fantastic job we need to let him
get on and do the job good to talk to
you thank you much indeed thank you